it's time for some jumping
i have a feeling i'm not gonna like this
challenge
nice job mick
what's up you're laughing
[Music]
what's that jumping i don't think that
was a jump right
at least the other leg wasn't there
this is this is gold man
[Music]
he did an extra jumbo
yes those shots
yes
[Music]
not for me
how do we do it afterwards
i think we got it now
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
i think that was it that was yeah i
think we got it i think we got it so you
might have seen bruce lee
playing ping pong with nunchucks we've
been watching youtube tutorials all
morning
hopefully we'll get at least one shot on
by the way
if you're a creator or just enjoy making
videos go and check out
epidemic sound we'll be using them in
all of our videos for the past year and
it's been really helpful
there's a free 30-day trial in the link
in our description
go and try out now to the nunchucks
it's good control i'm literally scared
to be here
the background is going better
[Music]
when it hits it really hits hard and
guys we post something new
every week so if you haven't subscribed
yet do it now so you don't miss out
[Applause]
another one another one
ah come on off door only one in a row
karate kid
[Music]
i went for it
[Music]
that actually hurts quite bad okay let's
continue
hahahahaha
that's that's pretty good and guys
remember to try out epidemic sound
even if you only use the free 30-day
trial you'll still be supporting our
channel
until next time double nunchucks
this is good but we need that one
it's like backspin topspin backspin
topspin backspin
don't try this at home